what's going on you're holding some
papers what's the big news in your world
yeah so the big news uh in my world is
they've discovered they've seen or they
think they've seen gravitational wave
background so this is a series of
experiments a bunch of experiments but a
bunch of different Pulsa timing arays
think they've seen a background of
gravitational waves and this this will
be the first time people have seen
anything like this this was in July and
it's really taken the taken the field by
storm since then it all happened on one
day all of the different Pulsar timing
array experiments put out papers which
just arrived in our inbox that morning
and they all had essentially the same
picture which was that they'd all seen
this background of gravitational waves
which is something people had theorized
about existing for a long time but
suddenly was seen how can they make this
clim oh great yeah so they have the most
ingenious uh observation uh that we live
on earth and surrounding us we have our
galaxy in our galaxies we have these uh
pulsers several pulsers these pulsers
are very fast rotating neutron stars and
they have this beam of light like a
lighthouse and once in a while the light
crosses our path and amongst these
pulsers there are some pulsers which are
actually millisecond so that means in a
second they rotate thousand times and
there are huge objects in the sky as
it's quite fast rotation that's crazy
fast isn't it super crazy fast okay and
then they are very very stable clocks
they're almost in fact until a decade
ago uh p where these millisecond pulsers
were the best clock that we ever had
okay so they are great time Keepers and
then imagine a gravitational wave
passing through them and a gravitational
wave is actually a stretch and
compression of space and it's a special
kind of stretch and compression which is
different from a soundwave which is also
a stretch and compression of space it's
just that in Soundwave compresses and
stretches a
medium let's say air water gravitational
wave can stretch and compress the fabric
of SpaceTime okay
the second thing second difference is
that it's what we call a quadripolar
compression which means uh that uh if a
gravitational wave is passing like that
then it will compress the space in One
Direction then it will stretch
simultaneously in the orthogonal
perpendicular Direction now if we are on
earth and we have bunch of uh pulsers
around them we know they timing pretty
well that great clocks as the
gravitational wave passes through them
let's say the gravit W stretches in that
direction so couple of pulsers which are
like this they get stretch like that and
the other two pulsers which are like on
the other side perpendicular to them
they get compressed towards Earth so you
would see that this Lighthouse signal
which is quite a good clock it comes to
you from these two directions quicker
than expected and the other two
directions slower than expected and
that's a tail tail signature of
gravitation waves so they have absorbed
these pulsers for about 15 years and
they have seen seen a yearly variation
in this kind of systematic pattern so
we've seen gravitational waves before
but the ones we've seen by ligo and
Virgo are a few kilometers long in terms
of their wavelength and this one is
slightly as long so it's a completely
different game what could have produced
them so definitely not the same things
as ligo and Virgo they're colliding
black holes aren't they exactly right
these colliding black holes they're a
few kilometers wide themselves and maybe
a few kilometers apart or tens of
kilometers so there's no way they can
make a wave on Lighty scales there's a
bunch of different possibilities and one
possibility is just a massive massive
black hole a super massive black hole
which is self is let's say a billion
times bigger than the previous black
holes we've seen and so pairs of those
colliding could potentially cause this
signal but there's a bunch of other
predictions as well which could cause
this signal so the waves that we've seen
are a background it's not like we've
seen them coming from a particular
direction um they they look more like
the waves on the sea not like a tidal
wave but like in general there's waves
people have thought that it might be a
bit like the COS microwave background
where we have light coming from from all
directions from the from the early big
bang and this would be like a similar
thing but in gravitational waves so we
have a gravitational wave background
it's kind of like the the waves of the
sea stretching and squeezing SpaceTime
quarks in the early Universe at very
very high temperatures uh in in the very
early Universe just after the hot big
bang are expected to be um free and kind
of move around freely happily but then
as the universe cooled at some point
those quarks got got trapped together
into hadrons into protons and into
neutrons and that happened at kind of a
moment uh in time when the universe was
about 10 to 12 Celsius or kelvin or
whatever uh obviously roughly the same
at that point if this happened in a kind
of dramatic way if if all the hadrons
when they were first produced uh
happened in what's called A first order
phase transition then then that could
have produced gravitational waves or
would have produced gravitational waves
and those could uh be the ones we're
seeing today um so so that's another
possibility another leading candidate to
explain the signal uh the signal is bit
too steeper than what black hole models
expect so we want some kind of signal
which goes Steep and high in amplitude
they can also caused by large Quantum
fluctuations in the early universe so we
see all these galaxies today in the
universe and we are very s that all
these galaxies are formed by tiny
Quantum fluctuations in the early
universe
which was created by inflation once in a
while inflation can create large Quantum
fluctuations especially large Quantum
fluctuations of small wavelength and
when these fluctuations uh in the later
Universe they start to push around the
plasma a lot once in a while the plasma
can collapse to form primordial black
holes and the overall effects would be
you have this compressed Plasma in the
early universe and any kind of
compressed plasma is a great source for
gravitational waves so you would also
see gravitational waves because of
compression of plasma and these are what
we call scalar induced gravitational
waves gravitational waves induced by
scalar density fluctuations or sound
waves they're probably one of the best
candidates that fit the data so that
they best fitting model so far and this
a topic that I work on so I'm also super
interested and excited about it is every
theorist looking at this data and
thinking oh this fits my idea and
everyone's trying to shape it to fit
their idea would have been nice but in
this paper
uh in the paper where they announced
that what kind of new physics can fit
this model they do a comparison between
different theories and they say which
Theory fits better and which doesn't and
there are some theories which fit better
than other theories which don't fit that
good so there is actually a hierarchy of
comparison between different theories
and uh what we have seen is Cosmic super
strings and these uh scalar induced
gravitational waves they fit the best
definitely better than supermassive
black holes at least 50 times better so
there's a factor they compute says the
probability of explaining the data
better than purely supermassive black
holes and for these models some of them
are 50 60 factors higher so quite well
explaining so the pictures show the
signal this picture for example shows
the signal in green and the prediction
from super massive black holes in blue
and you can see they don't quite agree
but they're not that far apart either
this plot at the beginning is partly
what motivates other new physics
explanations like this Quark had
transition you can see this this blue
area has quite large errow bars and
really we need to understand super
massive black holes better if we want to
to know if they can explain the signal
if these waves are passing through
everywhere all the time and they're
powerful enough to affect Pulsar why
aren't they affecting you and me why
don't we feel it why don't we get ripped
apart by it like it seems like these are
oh well they're powerful but gravity is
a weak Force so I'm being held as a as
one body through electromagnetic force
like my muscle Etc that's much much
stronger than gravity so if a
gravitational wave passes through me I
will get distorted just like the pulsers
uh but I won't feel it because it's
negligible compared to My overall size
however if you look at Earth and pulser
they're not held by electromagnetic
force they are H they just floating
around in space freely so a little bit
of change in their distance due to
gravitational waves can be caught by a
delay in a signal arrival time so that's
how you can use big scale Galactic scale
experiments to cast them I know you're a
theorist this is a result of some
experimental work as well clearly yeah
is this like a Triumph for the
experimentalists or is this like a great
moment for the theorists who's lording
it over who at the moment um yeah good
one I guess this is a Triumph of the
experimentalists and the theorists are
just hoping that the experimentalist can
do yeah I mean as we get to the 16 and
the 20year data set hopefully we'll have
a bit more data on like the spectral
shape of this or the type of waves the
amplitude of these waves and so on and
then we'll be able to tell which theory
is best uh but for now um it's difficult
to tell like the theorists have lots of
predictions and the experimentalists are
leading the way what's the next step in
this area of research is it going to
come from theorists do you need more
experiments what are we all waiting for
now what's the next hurdle yes from both
sides first of all we have this
observational tool they have this
amazing set of 68 millisecond pulsers so
they can test the timing even better and
better over the time as theorist of
early Universe uh we want to figure out
all the different processes which can
give rise to a gravitational wave signal
which matches with what we have seen
okay and there are several possible
scenarios uh which would uh emit
gravitational waves in the early
Universe when Universe was younger than
1 second old much younger than 1 second
or so it's a really early Universe in
fact all of those topics are pursued
here uh and and and some of us walk
actively on this topic so we have to
figure out what the signal is expected
from a theory so that we can test
directly I'm interested in the early
Universe I'm interested in particle
physics I want to know what the universe
is made of at the smallest scales like
what a quarks made of anything like
these kind of questions and with the
Large Hadron Collider you can only
Collide stuff so hard and eventually you
run out of being able to turn the energy
up and if we want to find out more about
particle physics we're going to have to
look now to the early Universe to
cosmology and with light we're stuck at
the cosmic microwave background because
before that time at higher energies in
the cosmic microwave background the
universe was opaque so light couldn't
pass through it but with gravitational
waves gravitational waves pass freely
through even the densest things they
pass through neutron stars for example
so we have like a direct signal from way
higher energy things going on and
possibly direct signals that can tell us
about what the universe is made of at
the smallest scales these what 60 yard
Pulsar being used as an instrument like
this was pretty clever isn't it like
yeah incredibly clever I think it was
Steven deweer that came up with this
like absolutely amazing idea so inspired
I don't know I guess it's the first time
we've had a bit of experimental kit
that's so much bigger than the earth do
check out the links on screen and in the
video description for more on the topics
we've covered today gravitational waves
large hron colada all that good stuff
and if you think you'd like to study or
work in the school of physics at the
University of Nottingham well there's a
link in the video description about that
as well they start going so rapidly
around one another they begin to
approach the speed of light in fact
something like 60% of the speed of light